[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans le cadre des journées de
l'architecturé
le p a fait visiter ses cibles de
projets
en particulier sur le sud du plateau de
saclay donc les quartiers de boulons et
l'école polytechnique
et cette année nous avons ajouté à ces
visites une visite un peu particulière
qui est celle du site qui se trouve
derrière moi on est sur l'usiné thomson
pour laquelle j'ai participé au sein de
l' agence renzo piano en
un bâtiment de 30 mille mètres carrés
situé à saint quentin en yvelines sur
l'ancien aérodrome de guyancourt un
terrain gigantesque de 22 hectares et
qui maintenant est complètement démolie
à 90% pour laisser la place à une zac la
zac des savoirs
et ça c'est absolument extraordinaire de
voir trente ans plus tard que ce projet
va avoir une deuxième vie finalement et
ça c'est très impressionnant pour un
architecte de voir que son bâtiment va
être réutilisées
ce site va constituer l'entrée du
quartier des savoirs qui lui sera un des
nouveaux quartiers de guyancourt autour
du métro et qui va accueillir environ
1800 logements et tous les équipements
et les commerces qui accompagne ce type
de nouveaux quartiers
il ya beaucoup de choses à refaire donc
ça ça va être la première étape pendant
ce temps là le chantier va se faire il
va y avoir une interaction entre les
deux et puis peut-être qu'un jour on va
faire la réhabilitation définitive de la
halle qui est une phase ultérieure
on va remettre en eau normes ce bâtiment
mais en lui gardant son caractère son
caractère toujours un peu industriels
il est important pour nous de faire
découvrir nos sites de projets parce
qu'en général ce sont des sites fermés
un petit peu méconnu du public qui sont
cachés derrière une clôture et donc des
journées comme celle-ci sont l'occasion
de les faire découvrir un petit peu
avant l'heure avant qu'ils deviennent de
vrais lieux de destination pour les
habitants du territoire